welcome back okay so we're talking about
system identification for control where
we have access to full state
measurements so the first thing I'm
going to tell you about is essentially
linear system identification using
dynamic mode decomposition with control
so let's just actually spell this out
dynamic mode decomposition with control
and this is work primarily by Josh
Proctor along with myself and Nathan
could so Proctor at all 2016 this is a
Sai ads paper so you can read about this
this method there but the basic idea is
that I can have measurements of my
system evolving in time measurements of
my control and put you as it evolves in
time and I'm going to use regression to
solve for these a and B matrices that
best fit the observed measurement so I'm
going to find the best fit linear
dynamical system that that agrees with
my measurements so in general this is
going to be framed in a discrete-time
setting so we could do this in
continuous time but in lots of
experiments we're actually going to have
measurements sequentially in time so I'm
just going to modify this to be X at
time k plus 1 equals a X at time k plus
bu at time K so this is just a
discrete-time version of my dynamical
system and what I'm going to assume kind
of the input to this method we're going
to assume that we have access to
measurements X in K so this is
measurements X let's say X at time 1 I'm
gonna make this look like a tall vector
X at time 1 X at time 2 dot X at time n
ok I'm also going to assume that I have
this so this is called my snapshot
matrix of my snapshots of my state in
time as it evolves in time so this is
time going from left to right I'm also
going to assume that I have what's
called X Prime and X prime is just the
snapshot matrix shift
one delta-t in the future so it starts
at X 2 X 3 and it goes to X n plus 1 ok
so this is the same basic assumption
that I start with with the regular
dynamic mode decomposition but then what
I assume I also have I have access to a
snapshot history of my control input and
I think Josh called this epsilon so
let's see if I can actually get my so
long to look ok and this is u 1 u 2 dot
dot dot u em okay so that's also a
matrix of my input measurements in time
okay so X and X prime are the original
inputs for DMD now I have this OOP salon
which will help me and interpret and
disambiguate the effective actuation and
the natural dynamics okay so this is the
input to the method and essentially what
I can do is I can write this discrete
time dynamical system directly in terms
of these data matrices okay so this is
kind of you know I could plug in X 1 X 2
and u1 or I can plug in X 2 u 2 and X 3
so essentially these are my X and
epsilon and this is my X prime variable
so I can write this in terms of my data
matrices as X prime the the matrix of
snapshots equals big a times big X plus
B times this matrix oops so on ok and
you can work this out this is now a
matrix system of equations but all of
the dimensions match ok so I can
multiply big x times my a matrix and it
essentially multiplies all of these
columns and multiplying by the a matrix
advances them 1 delta T in the future so
I get X prime if I take a times X plus B
times Epsilon ok and again I'm assuming
you already know how the dynamic mode
decomposition works which is essentially
just if you had X prime equals ax ok but
now we're gonna add this plus B oops
along ok so there are a couple of
interesting case
here I guess case one is a little bit
more more trivial so in case one we
actually know what B is let's say we
know we know what the B matrix is okay
so a is unknown but we know what B is we
know how we're affecting the system but
we don't know the dynamics a if we know
the matrix B essentially what we can do
is correct for this known B we can
essentially subtract it off to the left
side and we say okay we have X prime
minus B Epsilon
so these are all things we can measure
and that equals a times X where now this
is the only unknown okay so in this case
if you know B OOP salon X and X prime
you can essentially subtract this over
to the left hand side and this becomes
like a new X prime okay you can
essentially do this
the original DMD procedure but using
this new modified X prime this X and you
can solve for a in particular if this is
really high dimensional you can solve
for the leading eigen values and eigen
vectors of a for a reduced
representation which is the normal DMD
okay so case one if we know the B matrix
and we also have these these
measurements of what the control input
is in time we can just subtract this
over and solve for a just like we would
in regular DMD so this is kind of the
easy case okay this is easy
so the slightly harder case is case two
and in case - we don't know B so we
don't know B okay so in the case that we
don't know B we have to be a little bit
more clever and so what Josh did in this
case was essentially he stacked this up
and I hope I can actually get the
matrices right but he stacks this up
into a problem X prime equals and then
what he does is essentially build this
into a big
b-matrix so he builds this concatenated
matrix times a big X epsilon data matrix
okay so essentially he augments the he
splits this up so that you have one big
matrix of unknowns and one big matrix of
knowns so we know these and these are
unknown and then essentially he has a
procedure where you do dynamic mode
decomposition you run the dynamic mode
decomposition algorithm on on this
framework and you simultaneously using
data-driven regressions solve for this
big matrix that contains both a and B
this involves taking a singular value
decomposition of this matrix doing a
pseudo inverse and breaking up the
pieces until you get an a matrix and a B
matrix so there's a little bit more math
involved here you can read about it in
this twenty sixteen sigh ads paper but
basically in either case if I if I know
B then it's very easy to solve for the
dynamics a kind of this low order
representation if I don't know B I have
to simultaneously solve for a and B and
then I can do the regular dmg trick of
finding the leading eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of a okay so that's kind of
at the the mile-high view of dynamic
mode decomposition with control you
assume that you have quite a lot of
input data of your state as it evolves
in time along with your control inputs
you and then either if you have B or
don't have B you can solve for for the
unknown matrices and build a linear
reduced order model okay now a couple of
things I think are really interesting
about this method one thing is if you
didn't take into account this plus bu
you would essentially have you would
essentially just write an apply regular
DMD to solve for an a matrix but that a
matrix would be contaminated by the
effective control that you're not taking
into account so we'll do a little MATLAB
demo where we'll essentially compare
what happens if you do naive
DMD on a system that's being controlled
you'll get the wrong answer and then
we'll show that if you do this kind of
corrected DMD with control you can get
the correct a dynamics taking into
account B and one way I like to think
about this is essentially if I was doing
feedback control if I said u equals K X
okay so we often do u equals K X then if
u equals K X I essentially have my
dynamics as XK plus 1 equals a XK plus B
K XK that's my plus bu and that equals a
plus B K XK so what I'm getting at is if
I naively just do DMD on the data X
without taking into account the data you
the input data then I will get the wrong
dynamic so I'll get the essentially the
the modified dynamics and not the
original a and B matrices ok so there's
a fundamental ambiguity here where if I
if I actually have a system that's being
actively controlled u equals KX I can't
tell the difference between this
dynamical system with just an a matrix
with no forcing and this dynamical
system with an A and a B matrix and this
feedback law so in terms of regression
those are both valid solutions to the
data if my system is being controlled
and so often what I have to do is I have
to add some kind of a noise signal or
some kind of some kicks to my system
where I actually kick the you
occasionally to measure transients in
the dynamics ok so let me just let me
just recap ok we have a procedure to
identify models a and B from data if my
system is actively being controlled u
equals KX then there's a fundamental
ambiguity if I plug in u equals KX here
I get another dynamical system with a
different a matrix and this is equally
valid
to this so if I have a system that's
being actively controlled with a
feedback signal I have to kick the
control every once in a while I have to
kick you to get a little bit more
information out to get information out
of the system to disambiguate a and B
okay so we're going to code this up in
an example we'll see how it works you
can use these models directly for model
predictive control or to understand the
underlying dynamics and sensitivity of
your system thank you